all right you still got to see it you
were there for a couple of the days we
saw the workouts you watched them i
didn't i admit it i wish they were still
in the morning i could watch them while
i work i wasn't going to rearrange my
weekend to watch a bunch of guys running
around in their underwear sorry full
transparency i'm not doing it combine
superlatives time coming out of this
year's event chris what do you have
first well i i mean
let's just go with like
uh
like legs and butt for days tristan worf
so we didn't get to talk about that yet
because we we didn't hit it the first
but tristan worse the offensive lineman
from iowa i mean come on we talked about
some of the skill guys in the first hour
i mean we got a hit on him once again
mike i mean that was you know out of
this world 320 to run a 485 36 and a
half inch vertical 10-1 broad jump and
then the way he moved in drills and
everything like that along with just
again the way the body looks you know a
320 pound man who you know it doesn't
it's not your normal look of a 320 pound
man it's an upper body of a guy that
looks like you know oh hey he's 285 290
pounds because it's not sloppy but just
the power and explosion from a guy like
that to me you know that that was a
game-changing performance probably going
to be a first round offensive lineman no
matter what but when you put up those
type of numbers that moves you up like
10 spots in the round and now now he'll
be truly coveted as one of the number
one lineman in the draft and uh to me
that that was one we got to give love to
the big uglies every now and then
yeah i mean when a big guy has that kind
of athleticism and can move that way
there are so many different things you
can do with them you can get more
creative he can fit you know systems
where the offensive linemen are on the
move more and and you know just you
never know when you're going to need
somebody to put the pedal to the metal
on the football field and run across the
field and block somebody or or chase a
guy who intercepted a pass whatever the
case may be it's tools that are uncommon
for linemen and and yet to see a guy
that big move that way that is
incredible
i i ran a 482
and i was you know 95 pounds less than
him i mean that that to me is the
combine running the forward i'm running
running 40.
yes this is exactly what i was thinking
but i mean
what a freak of nature he is god i wish
i'd known you then but but you know uh i
i don't know that i could handle the 21
year old version of you i have a feeling
you're probably far more of a handful
than you are now yes all right uh this
is the not ready for primetime players
award because i don't like the fact that
they move the workouts to prime time and
i put out a very innocuous open-ended
not a push poll on twitter
24 600 votes so far how much the live
combine coverage did you watch this year
in comparison to last year
less has 65
of the vote less
and i know the ratings were up for
thursday uh when they moved it into the
evening from from the daytime but man i
i just i don't know that this is
sustainable especially when they are
going against real sporting events where
you turn it on and there's real
excitement they're actually keeping
score and it feels like watching golf
not that i have any problem with
watching golf but it's all very hush
tones and and it's individuals and
there isn't a whole lot happening and
and you can catch the big things on
twitter or espn's sportscenter after the
fact or on this show on monday morning
we'll tell you everything you need to
know you don't need to spend seven hours
four to eleven thursday friday saturday
night and then another five hour sunday
watching every minute of it and and i i
watched very very little of it and i
think a lot of people uh who are arden
football fans feel the same way because
fundamentally it's just not football
well no it's not football and you know
maybe the thing that's going to hurt
about hurt it a little bit is the fact
that yeah it's prime time on a friday
and saturday night is not you know i
think they're going to have to move the
days eventually that's to me where it's
got to be played i mean you're right
nobody's going to turn it on friday or
saturday night you know you might take a
quick look but there are guys or are
people going to sit there
for two and three hours at a time no
eventually they're gonna go out with
their wives or their friends and go to
the bar and do whatever that maybe take
a look here and there but if i'm the nfl
going forward i'm thinking okay from now
on let's try to make this to where it's
tuesday wednesday thursday night or
monday tuesday wednesday thursday night
something like that because then
mike florio's more inclined to be in the
barn on his recliner watching it right
oh and let me tell you i have watched a
lot of sports that i had not watched in
a long time i had never watched ufc when
there's a ufc pay-per-view we have a
gathering in the barn i mean it becomes
like a communal activity and it's fun
you get everybody together you have a
good time i didn't even dare send out to
the text chain of all the guys who come
to my barn hey let's watch the scouting
combine friday or saturday night they
would have laughed me off of the chain
yeah well
you're right i was that nerd that does
that okay i didn't do it saturday night
but friday night i did uh
but but i'm obsessed with it and this is
what i do and i wasn't feeling well so i
wasn't trying to go out on a friday
night but either way i enjoyed it
especially thursday night you know to me
that's where i'm just to my point have
it in the middle of the week and you're
going to get everybody to tune in and
sit there friday and saturday night
you're going to lose a crowd of people
that are gonna go do
i think you're right i think you're
right i think they and they look they've
already shown they're willing to
reconfigure it i think the bulk of it
needs to be tuesday wednesday thursday
night or you know do the four days
monday tuesday wednesday thursday but if
they're going to try to turn this into a
revenue generator a ratings generator
you you can't have four to eleven pm
eastern on a friday night and a saturday
night because people aren't going to
stay home to watch that all right what's
your next one um godzilla award okay i
mean godzilla okay it's makai becton
okay did you see that freaking dude i'm
mad i missed that interview last week
while i was puking my brains out in the
indianapolis hotel but again you know we
talked about some of the sexy skill guys
i don't want to talk about them all the
time i mean i want to talk about this
big freak of nature
364 pounds he ran faster than tom brady
did right at the combine all right he's
to move like that and forget all that
forget that he ran 5-1 which is
impressive some of the drill work he did
i mean this is not just some big slob
who weighs 360 pounds this is a dancing
bear as we would say in the nfl he's a
special athlete so there's another guy
that you know i just want to give the
little notice to because we're talking
about a this is a you know trent brown
right orlando brown the baltimore ravens
type guy where it might not always look
pretty and super athletic but the size
of the human being is different for even
the nfl and yeah there might not be
quite the foot quickness you want
prototypically out of that guy all right
but it's not letting that much less than
and you know this guy could cast a
shadow around planet earth so to get
around him and his long arms too is not
easy either which makes up for the fact
that his feet might not be as quick but
to me that was another impressive
performance that i just got to talk
about i mean to be that big and to move
that way it just speaks to the athletes
that are coming into the nfl right now
six seven three sixty and you're right
to move like that incredible and
uh i i i look forward to a creative
coach finding ways to use him uh line
him up in the backfield make make him
eligible let him catch a pass in the end
zone let him let him run something other
than a short little route let him let
him get a head of steam behind him and
and good luck if you're a safety getting
in his way if he has the ball in his
hands so uh that was impressive and you
know what's funny when they come around
for the interviews they're wearing the
baggy clothing so you really don't get a
sense i mean for me it's just like
looking up and at a giant you don't
sense how big the guy is right um when
they when they're you know you can't
hide anything in the underwear that they
wear for the combine you can't hide
anything in the underwear for the
combine
chris jones found that out the hard way
four years ago but uh but any anyway i
digress uh yeah you really get a sense
for how massive these guys are when they
move like that it really is impressive
all right this is the i choose not to
run award for chase young and anyone
else who makes the conscious decision
not to work out and doesn't give in
to the pressure and i think they're
getting more creative on how they they
go after the guys who choose not to work
out it used to be very blatant and very
open where people in the media would say
oh what's wrong don't you want to
compete aren't you a competitor these
guys are out here competing baloney
they're not competing in football and
chase young told me directly last week i
didn't want to take the time necessary
to become a combine athlete i wanted to
continue to work on becoming the best
football player i can be so when it's
time to show up and practice and play
football i'll be more prepared it is a
unique skill set to morph into an
underwear olympian and i admire chase
young for holding firm the thing i don't
like though is you know all of a sudden
we start hearing oh chase young didn't
have a sack in any of his last three
games who cares if he had a sack or not
but you know you buck the system chris
and the system finds a way to buck back
no well no doubt you're all of a sudden
oh i don't know if he hustles every play
as motor i mean all those kind of things
you're right are all going to be
questioned a little bit but it doesn't
matter he's put on enough on his plate
and to come out of a place like ohio
state right now that's just you know
through the roof with pass rushers and
the fact that those people are going to
go oh he's like a nick bosa oh he's like
a joey bosa
i think that's going to silence a lot of
the haters and criticism there in a
hurry but he's one of those guys still i
can't wait to see his pro day because i
think he is going to do something that
we just go whoa like an isaiah simmons
or uh a chase clay pool that we saw this
year where we just go and it just
doesn't make sense to be that size and
look like that and be able to move the
way they do that's why the last one like
if i could do one more superlative like
holy wide receiver i mean it's just one
freak after another i mean that would be
the probably my main thing that jumped
out from the combine i just can't get
over the amount of talented physically
gifted wide receivers that are in the
class of course hey it was great to see
henry ruggs right i mean whoa could he
fly you know you could tell he felt the
pressure of the moment too and he wanted
to do something special but then you
know whether you talk about the kid from
colorado chase claypool denzel mims
donovan people jones jerry judy who i
thought overall looked about as good and
as smooth as any receiver there running
a 4-4 justin jefferson same thing from
lsu they might not had the fastest times
but they had times where you go whoa
he's still really fast and they look
like the most polished wide receivers of
the group too but that's the one thing
that jumped out to me mike i just
sitting there thursday night every
receiver that got up i just kept going
wow he looks good whoa okay he can run
whoa he could jump wow he looks good
whoa he can run i mean it's unbelievable
the amount of talented receivers that
are coming in the league this year in
the draft hey chris and that means it's
bad news if you're a free agent receiver
or like a stefan diggs if the vikings
are thinking about trading and why would
you give up anything of value for a
veteran receiver and take on an
eight-figure contract when you can draft
one or two of these guys at very very
low salaries in comparison to what the
best players the most established
players in the league make yeah you're
right well you know and last year mike
to your point
you know we could point at two
second round picks who changed their
team at wide receiver debo samuel for
the 49ers dk metcalf for the seattle
seahawks you know to your point that's
ex that's spot on those are two guys
that became go-to targets for their team
that were found in the second round and
i think you're gonna find a number of
receivers in this draft that are go-to
type material that are drafted in the
second and third round
hey and that could ultimately make it
very good for the cowboys who if the new
cba goes through they'll have a
franchise tag to use on dak prescott and
mark cooper for whom they gave up a
first round pick back in the 2018 season
he goes to the market maybe the market
won't be there for amari cooper because
why am i going to sign amari cooper and
pay him 16 17 18 19 million a year or
more
when i can get one of these kids right
out of school and there's so many of
them this year the the dollar for dollar
value is there for the youngsters and it
may not be right there relatively
speaking for amari cooper
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports